Vectors can be represented
through their components.
If we have a vector
A, we can decompose it
into its components in
the x and y-directions
by finding the vectors, one
along x and one along y,
that add up to
the vector A. This
is the same thing as finding
the projections of the vector A
along the x and y-axes.
Here is the projection
of the vector
onto the x-axis,
its x-component.
And here is the projection onto
the y-axis, the y-component.
This particular vector
could be written
as A is equal to minus
2i hat plus minus 2j hat.
A generic vector
in two dimensions
can be written as A is equal
to Ax, the x-component of A,
times i hat, the unit
vector along x, plus Ay,
the y-component, times j
hat, the unit vector along y.
If the vector is in
three dimensions,
we will also have
an Az times k hat.
What if we have the vector
minus 3i hat plus 2j hat?
First we find the vector
minus 3 times vector i hat
and add this to the
vector 2 times j hat.
We can draw this
vector anywhere.
It doesn't have to
start at the origin.